very scary for women as well to create a  family in these days with these kind of  men there's a lot of men are behaving  like women and women are behaving like  men right so we are chasing the back yes  because we met a lot of men they are  just like [ __ ] boys you know and they  just wanted they they pretend to lure  you in with you know presence and love  mommy but you realize like we we choose  the men that are [ __ ] boys we choose  them because we we Overlook 80 of men do  you know how many [ __ ] ways are out  there and many good okay guys  let me know I'm interested so when I let  me know where when I think of a [ __ ] boy  I think of a guy that's talking and  sleeping with multiple girls right would  you say that's what you would Define oh  okay I had a [ __ ] while he was only  sleeping with me but